[Music]
take him out
the division resurgence in the
lore is starting right before the
division one event and then you will
have the bulk of the content after the
division one basically between the
division one and the division two so
that's like brand new
stories but totally consistent with what
has been set in the division one and the
division two the the division resurgence
is
set in new york city one of the
objective was to come back to the vibe
of the division one that was very strong
and loved by the community it's always a
great experience to to get you know
familiar things that you wish to explore
seen through the length of the game for
example we have the full mission on
liberty island you see the statue of
liberty from afar it feels like a known
place but for us it was very important
to come back to the roots of the game
on target we just had our first close
alpha and it's very interesting to see
that people reacted quite positively of
the fact that it's a true mmo in the
sense that you can
meet real players
while exploring the open world not only
in the state of place but also in the
middle of the street and
to have some some very interesting
encounters i was also surprised to see
that some people were happy to see that
their character was actually speaking
now i'll kill every last one here
the division resurgence class system
there will be six classes in that first
alpha we did introduce three of them
which which are the demolitionists and
the whole work
and the goal is really to find synergies
when you're playing cooperation in teams
so with the with the demolitionist it's
basically the heavy gun a large
area of effect and and you can basically
engage
the enemies in groups and and try to fix
them on specific spots
you have the ball walk which is more
like a tank melee where you can with
your shield go in close quarter use your
shotgun and try to take advantage and
basically uh get the intention of the
enemies
while you're progressing you can start
to tune
each
skills each specific power of those
classes to to get very specific on what
you're doing
what are the difference between the
division one and uh and the division two
first it's really consistent but it's
like a brand new story uh and we're
adding new stuff like uh new factions
with the freeman new heroes new vlans
and and also additional classes that
bring something new to the recipe but
staying very true to what is a division
when are we gonna learn more about the
division resurgence you will learn what
are the next stage what are we cooking
for you at the ubisoft forum on
september 10th
rounds of cover
you